I need three years old former President
Jimmy Carter is still actively finding
ways to serve his country he and his
wife Rosalyn have volunteered with
Habitat for Humanity since 1984 together
they have helped build or remodel more
than 4200 homes in an interview you will
only see on CBS this morning we spoke to
the President Carter on a project
outside South Bend Indiana and met some
other famous volunteers nearly 40 years
after leaving the White House Jimmy
Carter's legacy is still building it is
nearly 94 degrees outside what are you
doing here
well I'm building Habitat houses with
his wife Rosalyn President Carter has
put in 34 years helping make more than
4,000 homes in 14 countries I understand
that you and says Carter renovated your
home the two of you did you use the
skills of habitat to do absolutely yeah
what did you do well we contracted with
a copper man he didn't show up when he
said he would so we decided we just do
it ourselves you know any married couple
that's been together for as long as you
have when they do a project together I
mean is this smooth sailing with the two
though how's it going oh we're not even
I have at that site we've been married
now as you know a little over 72 years
and so we've learned to accommodate want
to know then and I know those
differences measure twice and cut once
is good for carpentry and maybe for
marriages it is we saw that precision up
close when we joined the Carters at
their latest Habitat for Humanity
community near South Bend Indiana there
are 1700 volunteers working here what
does that tell you about America it
tells me that America has a great
orientation toward helping people in
need it's very difficult for somebody
who's well-off to cross a barrier and
get in touch with a very poor family
who's in need and never has had a decent
home but habitat provides that Avenue
very automatically in the process
inspiring others to come out swing
like comedian David Letterman I should
be thanking you for allowing me to help
out and do this well thank you well you
do you could Morgan don't have a debt
for a long time and I didn't know about
it yeah we started right after Katrina
and found the experience as you know
overwhelmingly gratifying he credits
President Carter seeing him and being
here on these builds is such a lovely
break from the cynicism of life because
just listen to this it's it's delightful
you're not just taking out a little tack
hammer you're down in Houston you're in
the suit mucking out them yeah
soggy insulation is this it was a
mistake getting around it it was a job
for a younger braver man but yes we were
doing it and when you're hammering are
you taking more care than if you were
building something in your own backyard
yeah if I screw up the hammering that
means I have to go to the claw part of
the hammered spend the next half hour
doing that while everyone's looking at
me Dave you're you know you're holding
up the bill and you don't want that
Jimmy Carter only served one four-year
term in the White House so he never met
the five-year requirement for a federal
pension but he isn't planning on
retiring already a former presidents for
longer than anyone in history you said
you thought that telling the truth was
important when you were president but
you seem to suggest it might not be so
important to the presidency
well that seems to be the case now you
know I think there's it's well known
that didn't cover President it's very
careless where the truth telling the
truth has been pretty deep ingrained in
me and I think that makes it even more
deplorable to me to see that it's been
abandoned by some people what some
people would say well that's that's
politics you know you maybe you have to
tell lie now and again and maybe even
more than that but you can you can
succeed for your side and get things
done
I disagree with that I think I went
through my campaign and my presidency
without ever lying to the people while
making a deliberately false statement
and I think that would be a very
worthwhile thing to reinsert into
politics these days the current
presidents changed the office around a
lot of different ways do you ever look
at the presidency and say boy I wish I
could have done that it would have been
a lot easier not really not ever seen
much to be emulated in recent months but
uh well you know I'm not here to
criticize the incoming president oxide I
just wish him well and you know I prayed
for him where do you see hope than in
today for the for the rebirth of America
or for the rebounding that people are
are looking for there's bound to come in
our country through the electoral
process and I think that America will
learn from its mistakes we don't always
like the best person that's obvious I
think you 13 the time when I ran perhaps
but I think America and eventually
prevails
so did you hear that she said including
the time when I ran perhaps like number
one John it was so good to see him again
and it's just a reminder of what what
this country is really about and I like
how he ended with ultimately America
will prevail I like that I'm also struck
and having seen him recently too
he has spent his life in service to his
country he's a former Navy man and even
after office with his wife has dedicated
his life this cause habited always
thinking about the other that's right
other than himself and we're reminded of
that she was McCain's passing well
McCain was selfish in many ways he would
admit he was so dedicated to the service
of his country that's right the
transitive property of that self
selflessness is what hooked Letterman
that's the thing that's amazing is
Letterman was a call as Carter a beacon
so that selflessness you described is
not just one person doing something yeah
it literally draws others and that's
what was so powerful not just about
David Letterman but the 1,700 other
volunteers who were spending a week
there putting them houses for people to
give them a good start and may I say
it's always good to see David Letterman
I got a big kick out of seeing him yeah
it looks good missing a Santa suit
though and the gifts I me about
Letterman like Santa he's been doing it
working on those houses quietly and
anonymously for a long time so he's
putting his service into action as well
and today on the CBS this morning
podcast you can hear our full interview
with David Letterman you can find it on
Apple's podcast app or wherever you like
to download your podcasts